Київ, проспект Перемоги.
Інспектори Вадим та Володимир щойно заступили на зміну.
В одного в руках лазерний прилад TruCam, в іншого - жезл і свисток.
Разом ловлять любителів натиснути на газ.
Уже місяць, як патрульні проводять фото- та відеофіксацію за допомогою цього приладу.
Щодня виписують понад сто штрафів.
Водій Максим претензій до інспекторів не має.
Порушив швидкісний режим, 75 кілометрів десь, до 80-ти.
Нечасто, просто сьогодні не встиг на базу за товаром.
Про місце контролю інформує дорожній знак та увімкнені проблискові маячки на службовому авто.
Втім, водії не лише ігнорують ці підказки, але й часто - свисток патрульних.
Тоді інспектори самі сідають за кермо і тиснуть на газ.
Втікача знайшли у дворах, за два кілометри від місця фіксації порушення.
- Що ви мені показуєте?
- Фіксацію вашого правопорушення.
- Ви що, прикалуєтесь?
Це моя машина?
Давайте, будь-яку людину запитайте,
це моя машина? Це не моя машина.
Залежно від погоди і часу доби інспектори задають
параметри, на яких здійснює фотофіксацію прилад TruCam.
5, 10 чи максимально 40 метрів. Лазер точно встановлює швидкість авто,
проте картинка на моніторі не завжди якісна.
До того ж, часто буває, що номери автівки порушника затуляє інша машина.
- Якщо прилад не зафіксував номерного знаку, то дуже тяжко.
Є свідомі водії, вони погоджуються і говорять, що
так, я порушив, але якщо немає доказу, то не можна притягнути людину до відповідальності.
Якщо перевищив дозволену швидкість на 20 кілометрів, сплачуй 250 гривень.
Якщо на 50 - 510.
Деякі патрульні авто мають при собі прилад для зчитування банківських карт.
Утім, найчастіше водіям просто вручають чек.
За законом, ті мають 15 діб на оплату.
Потім сума удвічі збільшується. Та обурює водіїв
не стільки штраф, як обмеження швидкості на проспектах.
- На такій трасі з відбійником і трьома полосами,
чотирма, я не знаю…. Я не бачу, щоб хтось взагалі їхав 50 км/год.
Фіксація швидкості ведеться на небезпечних ділянках доріг
міжнародного значення і в місцях з високим рівнем ДТП.
Карту розташування можна знайти на фейсбук-сторінці Патрульної служби.
На всю Україну є 25 приладів TruCam, і лише два - в Києві.
Незабаром їхня кількість має суттєво зрости.
Це полегшить контроль на дорогах. На такі зміни патрульні сподіваються вже до нового року.
- Система автоматичної фото- відеофіксації - вона
зараз розробляється і знаходиться на останній стадії впровадження.
Система автоматичної фіксації, яка діяла, якщо я не помиляюсь,
у 2008 році, але була запущена наспіх.
Дійшло до того, що Конституційний суд виніс вирок даній системі і знівелював її повністю.
І для того, щоб не наступати на тіж самі граблі ще раз, треба все зробити дуже виважено.
Окрім того, в патрульній поліції анонсують збільшення штрафів
у 6 разів. Приміром, за порушення обмеження швидкості руху
в майбутньому доведеться віддати понад 3000 тисячі гривень.
Верховна Рада вже посилила відповідальність
за керування транспортними засобами в стані алкогольного чи наркотичного сп’яніння.
Із січня 2020-го це буде прирівняно до кримінального проступку
і коштуватиме від 17 до 34 тисяч гривень.
Ще рано казати, чи зменшиться кількість ДТП після появи на дорогах TruCam.
Зате в Патрульній службі підрахували інші цифри:
понад 10 тисяч виписаних штрафів наповнили український бюджет
на 2,5 мільйони гривень.
Інспектори Вадим та Володимир бачать це по-своєму:
для них збережена гривня - це інколи і збережене життя.